Here's how this works in the blind signatures protocol.
Alice will generate not one message now but a hundred messages.
Each one of this form but with a different value for r1.
Alice will also pick a hundred k values. Send all of those to the bank.
The bank picks some random value x between 1 and 100 and unblinds all the other messages
so that means that the bank will send x to Alice.
Alice needs to send something back to the bank that the bank can use to verify
that all these messages, other than message x, contain something like this.
So, what should Alice send back to the bank?
Te set of all the ri values except for the one corresponding to message x.
The set of all the ki values except for the one not matching x.
Both of these or none of these work?